je travaille avec des gens assez marrant
eux
notamment christophe salengro qui amène
une distance un humour
[Musique]
hu
salengro qu'est ce que vous faites dans
cette galère eh bien
en avignon depuis que france easter a
joué le cid ça ça un peu bloqué tous mes
roues alors voilà je me retrouve avec
philippe découflé mais ça va être
agréable
vraiment c'est un spectacle extrêmement
sympathique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs soyez les
bienvenus au théâtre en plein air
d'albertville en savoie la savoie qui
s'honore de votre venue
et vous donne aujourd'hui le bon jour
par ma voix la multiprise
quand j'étais à l'école du ces le
va-et-vient à l'électricité la fée
électricité
je crois que j'aime bien les gens assez
personnalisé et il aime bien que ce soit
pas forcément onze personnes exactement
pareil donc il joue beaucoup avec les
différences entre les gens et c'est pour
ça qu il veut aussi des gens comme moi
qui sont pas vraiment danseurs alors on
les reconnaît reconnaît les différences
longueur de cheveux aux couleurs des
vêtements au fait qu'il a des lunettes
est pas l et à quelques autres points
plus difficile à percevoir sur ce bon
soir
on se connaît depuis dix ans et on on
s'aime et puis on s'engueule aussi pas
mal des rapports créatifs comme on
je vais remonter parce que j'ai mal aux
gens
[Musique]